- Document versus create.
(tranquil music)
People aren't starting,
they're just not making,
they're thinking, they're
pondering, they're strategizing,
they're debating.
A lot of people look at finished products,
they look at LeBron today,
they look at Kobe today,
they look at Beyonce today.
The difference between
understanding who you are
versus who you wish you were.
If you wanna be respected
and really known,
- [Man] Show up.
- show the fuck up.
Enough listening, start doing shit,
don't be scared, and if you're scared
find somebody who's not
scared, make them your partner,
it's action, it's going, it's doing.
And if you're passionate
about something in your world,
you could make a big difference,
you gotta pump out content.
Wine Library TV work,
and Steve I look like a hostage in Iraq.
Hello everyone, and welcome
to the first episode
of Wine Library TV.
But here's where people
that pump out content
make a mistake,
they care about the camera,
and the lighting, and all
that other horse crap.
It means nothing.
Everything I believe in was
not possible five years ago.
Anybody can get in the game
and talk about the things
they love the most,
build a business around their passion.
Hello everybody, this is Gary Vaynerchuk
and this is my one twenty.
Hey everybody it's Gary
Vaynerchuk at GaryVaynerchuk.com
playing with air time, not
really it's down right now.
You know, that's the whole promise
that we never believed before,
which was do what you love.
You always heard do what you love
but you won't make as much money.
You know, the game has changed,
you know, we talk about
all these products.
Don't be scared to be multi-dimensional.
You're not unfocused.
You know, nobody in this world
should define who you are.
You can be so many things.
You can crush it doing video blogging,
and you can crush it doing blogging.
I mean, it just comes down
to what are you good at?
I think that's been turned on its head.
Do what you love and you'll probably make
more money than you could ever imagine.
I think it's much smarter
for you to talk to the world
about your process of going through this,
than the advice that you think
you should be giving them.
(light piano music)
I think documenting your journey on media,
your own personal blog, YouTube
The Ice Bucket Challenge.
Bring it Nate, I know
you're gonna love this.
Holy!
SoundCloud, Anchor, you
know, on and on and on
Snapchat on and on and on.
Hey guys, I know I look like the emperor
from Star Wars right now,
but
Of you going through this journey
I mean it would be really cool
to have content right now about when
Vera Wang started learning
like, literally learning
how to
how to create a dress, right?
We are sitting where the gatekeepers
are no longer in control.
Guys, I was in my office in the dirty Jers
right?
And I started taping Wine Library TV
One of the great things about the LAB
is that D walks around a whole lot
and somethings are obviously
gonna be for show but
sometimes things come along
and they can stand alone.
You need to be thinking about documenting
more than you need to be
thinking about creating.
- What do you think the
appeal is of the daily shit.
- I think that I wish I
documented all my truths
to this level
because all the people that
think I was smart about Twitter,
they don't even know how much.
And I think this will do that.
Why do people always say stick to wine?
Stick to what you know.
Stick to science.
Stick to cooking.
Why do we always want
other people to stick to?
I don't want to stick to crap.
You know what I wanna stick to?
I wanna stick to what makes me happy.
I wanna wanna execute again,
that's what I wanna do.
You didn't think it was
true that they were fifteen,
sixteen hours a day.
You thought they were hyperbolized,
and they were eight or nine.
You didn't realize that
every minute was something.
You didn't realize that it's everyday.
I wish I did this seven years ago,
I wish you got to see
the last seven years.
Every minute, every day.
Always,
forever.
(soft piano)
The world is changing,
we're more connected,
and your legacy, your maneuvering,
your decision-making process
has to start at your long-term legacy.
Big picture always wins.
If you're pumping out good shit,
people will follow.
But if you for a second,
a half a second,
don't believe in what you're doing,
whether it's your personal brand,
or the product you represent,
you need to get out now.
You always think of the big picture,
the legacy.
Who are you going to be viewed at
when it's all said and done?
If I actually, from where I started,
go on to buy a $4 billion
sports organization
and I documented the entire journey
my words are motivating
and I'm good at that
but the reason I do DailyVee
and the reason I'm documenting so much
is if I can put out a body
of work forty years from now
that showed the process of a
young man that put in the work
had the vision, did it the right way,
tried to help people along the way,
because he was trying to
build the biggest building
in town by building it,
not by tearing everybody
else's buildings down,
and then I actually accomplish it.
Well that becomes a real, a real
a real great American Dream story.
And this is why I want to
build a massive business
because I want to teach the
world that you can build
a billion dollar empire on good.
(applause)
Like there's no reason
this unfortunate narrative
that affected a lot of
my friends of Steve Jobs.
Like it became the move to be a dick
because you're gonna get
the best work out of people?
I'll tell you right now, I'm forty,
so far here's what I got for you,
people work way better when
you deploy honey than vinegar.
I've gotten much better work out of people
'cause they're guilted to let me down
versus being scared of me.
Get the fuck outta here.
You should start a pillar show whether it
I mean, vlogging I think
is very fascinating.
You know you should be
doing Instagram stories
and Snapchat stories at scale.
You should be putting
out seven to twenty-five
pieces of content on both
those platforms a day.
- [Man] A day?
- And let me explain how, don't go fancy.
Document versus create.
It's a big, it's a big shift.
When I say seven to twenty-five,
you say, my god, how do I
produce seven to twenty-five
meaningful things that
will have me respected,
versus document.
You gotta put out stuff,
and you gotta fabricate it.
Like when you're
I still can't believe how many people
that live in New York
don't use New York people.
If I were you and I had an hour right now,
go in the fucking park right now,
right now, like, I don't know
like, go back to your basketball roots.
Stand outside the garden
right there and be like,
what do you think about
the Knicks upcoming season?
Yeah, interview four people.
One person gets into a
thoughtful conversation,
he was the former ballboy in 1957.
It's a nice story, and boom!
You see where I'm going?
People aren't starting,
so you can't create?
Distribute.
There's no excuse for
not talking to the world,
it just doesn't have to be your thoughts
and words every time.
My friends, the key to content success
is you gotta start documenting
instead of creating.
Let me tell you how, just start.
(music fades)